Peter when should a screenwriter give up
on a screenplay yeah yeah wow that wow
that's sort of like asking when do you
give up on a marriage because you can
give up on a marriage at any point haha
you know it's like okay we've been to
counseling okay we thought that was
going to work well okay did you want to
go see another counselor or not there's
no good answer that and I'm sorry to be
mealy-mouthed because I've had writers
who have had scripts that they haven't
been able to sell in 15 years they turn
to them again and they they go wow I'd
say if you are tired of the story put it
away and then come back to it in a year
or two it's amazing what happens when
you do that there's something about time
that gives you a complete perspective
and will help you maybe understand
what's wrong with a story in 10 minutes
whereas you've been struggling with it
and struggling with it and you can't
realize what's wrong with it I've seen
writers put a story away for a year come
back to it and go oh my god I know
exactly what's wrong with I know how to
fix it there are new there is never a
point for you to say I will never ever
touch the script again ever it's if
you've written something down it's going
to be valuable to you it I've seen it
all the time happened that a writer has
worked four or five years on a project
and said I will never touch it again
picked it up even four or five years
later and Ben reinstall the worst judge
of whether it's good or not of anybody
you should i always tell writers this
try not to read your writing for at
least a week or two when you're writing
it try to get some perspective on it
chances are what you've written is has
some brilliance in it
but you won't know you have no
perspective in a day or two you need
time to know whether it's good or not
this is why that cliche about working
every day whether you are inspired or
not it is so important and I see it in
professional writers all the time even
if they literally are in agony as they
type and go this is this is crap
this is crap you never know what the
gold is going to be from that writing
whereas if you don't write it down if
you go you know what today is just too
tough it's too hard I have no
inspiration I'm not going to write
because I know when i write this is crap
those people fail almost all the time
because they don't ever write on a
discipline schedule so they're never
they don't have crap that they can go
back in and go oh look here's a gold
nugget oh here's another gold nugget I
guarantee if you write five pages of
what you think is utter crap that within
that you'll find a paragraph if you give
yourself enough time that will literally
propel you another chapter or two or
another scene or two and that's what
that's sort of a secret of a
professional writer that really
distinguishes him from an amateur writer
is that they will write on a schedule no
matter whether or not they've got
needles sticking in their eyes they'll
just go ahead and sit down and write
you